ENEMY OF LYING, POMPOSITY,
SMUGNESS, AND GROUPTHINK.
"HANNITY" IS NEXT.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: A FOX NEWS ALERT, IT
IN TONIGHT WITH A MASSIVE, HUGE
MYSTERY OUT OF OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL, WASHINGTON, D.C., THAT
IS LITERALLY AS WE SPEAK
REACHING A FEVERED PITCH.
JUST TO IS THAT HEARSAY,
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER/WHISTLE-BLOWER
TONIGHT, REAL CLEAR
INVESTIGATIONS POLLS FERRY IS
REPORTING THE DETAILS OF THIS
PERSON'S IDENTITY.
AND BE VERY, VERY CLEAR, LINE OF
DEMARCATION.
THERE ARE THINGS TONIGHT THAT
ARE SO SCARY THAT WE CAN REPORT.
WE WILL IDENTIFY THEM.
WE CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM
THE REPORT, AND WE WILL NOT GO
WITH THE NAME OF THE IDENTIFIED
PERSON UNLESS WE HAVE FINAL
CONFIRMATION.
I CAN CONFIRM TO YOU AFTER
MAKING NUMEROUS CALLS IN THE
LAST HOUR, THIS IS THE
INDIVIDUAL, THE MOST TALKED
ABOUT IN WASHINGTON AS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
AND IF HE IS CORRECT, TURNS OUT
TO BE CORRECT IN WHAT HE IS
REPORTING TONIGHT, WE ARE
LOOKING AT A SCANDAL OF
MONUMENTAL PROPORTION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, WHAT WE
ARE WATCHING IS THIS BEATING OF
PROCESSES OF THIS IMPEACHMENT
WITCH HUNT WITH WHAT WE KNOW.
I CAN TELL YOU TONIGHT, WE
CANNOT CONTINUE UNTIL QUESTIONS
ARE ANSWERED.
REPUBLICANS TONIGHT MUST NOW
DEMAND ANSWERS BEFORE ANYTHING
MOVES FORWARD.
THEY MUST DEMAND TO KNOW IF, IN
FACT, THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS A
DEEP STATE OPERATIVE.
THEY NEED TO DEMAND TO KNOW NOW.
WE DO KNOW THERE WAS CONTACT
WITH A CORRUPT AND COWARDLY AND
COMPROMISED GENERAL WIRE
ADAM SCHIFF'S OFFICE.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THAT
CONTACT IS.
EVERY BIT OF THAT CONTACT.
WE NEED TO DIM ANTENNA WITH THIS
PERSON, IN FACT, WHOEVER THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER IS, DID
THEY ABUSE THEIR POWER, THEIR
POSITION AT THE CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY?
WE NEED TO KNOW NOW IF, IN FACT,
THIS PERSON WAS WORKING ON A
MAJOR POLITICAL AGENDA,
SUPPORTING A DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS
SUPPORT OF A CANDIDATE FROM THE
IG, WHICH WE WILL GET TO.
WE NEED TO DEMAND TO KNOW THAT
TONIGHT THE RELATIONSHIP AND THE
CONTACT WITH FORMER BOSS, AND
THAT WOULD BE BRENNAN.
HIS NAME COMES UP A LOT, DOESN'T
IT?
THE WHOLE THING, WHAT WE KNOW
STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
WE NEED TO KNOW WITH THE TOOLS
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
WILL ONCE AGAIN WEAPONIZE AND
TURN AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE NEED TO KNOW WITH
HIGH-RANKING OBAMA OFFICIALS
WERE YET, AGAIN, INVOLVED IN AN
EFFORT TO OVERTURN THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE, AND ELECTION.
NOW, WE CANNOT AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR, CONFIRM REAL CLEAR THE
REPORT.
WHAT IS ALREADY BEING REPORTED
IS CHILLING.
WE NEED ANSWERS, AND WE NEED
THEM LIKE YESTERDAY.
WE NEED TO KNOW THE IDENTITY OF
THIS NONWHISTLE-BLOWER AS A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE NEED TO KNOW IF THEY HAVE AN
AGENDA.
WE NEED TO KNOW WITH THE INTEL
COMMUNITY INSPECTOR GENERAL,
WHEN HE SAID THIS HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER FAVORED A
POLITICAL CANDIDATE, THAT WAS A
DEMOCRAT.
WHAT CANDIDATE WAS THERE ANY CON
ADDICT?
WE KNOW THERE WAS CONTACT WITH
ADAM SCHIFF'S OFFICE.
THAT MAKES HIM A FACT WITNESS.
THAT MAKES HIM A COMPROMISE
CHAIRMAN.
HE HAS IN NO POSITION TO LEAD
ANY EFFORT TO IMPEACH ANYBODY
EXCEPT HIMSELF.
HE NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
NOW, WE KNOW A TOWN THAT LOVES
TO LEAK HAS BEEN REMARKABLY
QUIET ON THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
IDENTITY.
WE KNOW HE WAS MENTIONED ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE.
WE KNOW HE WAS MENTIONED IN THE
SECRET SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
WE KNOW THAT EVERYONE IN THE
MEDIA.
I CAN SPEAK FROM PEOPLE I KNOW,
PEOPLE OF FAKE NEWS CNN, AT THE
AREA 51 BOSWELL RACHEL MADDOW
CONSPIRACY CHANNEL, MSNBC.
THEY KNOW THIS PERSON'S NAME.
IT IS NOW CLEAR.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
IN OTHER WORDS, WEEK, WE THE
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW BEFORE
ANYTHING ELSE MOVES FORWARD.
NOW, MAKES YOU WONDER, WHY WOULD
THEY WANT TO RUSH SOMETHING AS
IMPORTANT AS IMPEACHMENT?
WHY NO DUE PROCESS FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
WHO IS THE PERSON THAT STARTED
THIS ENTIRE UKRAINIAN, WHAT WE
NOW KNOW TO BE A REAL
WITCH HUNT?
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THE
INTERPRETATION THAT WE WERE
GIVEN BY THE CORRUPT,
COMPROMISED, COWARDLY AND LIAR,
ADAM SCHIFF WAS WRONG.
IT WAS FALSE.
WE WERE TOLD THAT THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER SAID QUID PRO QUO
TOOK PLACE.
BUT WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
THAT TRANSCRIPT EXONERATES
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMPLETELY.
THAT TRANSCRIPT REVEALS THESE
CLAIMS WERE FALSE, YES, THE
COMPROMISED, CONGENITAL LIAR.
WE NEED TO KNOW WITH THIS PERSON
IN FACT HAD A POLITICAL AGENDA.
WHETHER THERE WAS COLLUSION WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE.
WITH HER COLLUSION WITH
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THEY SUPPORTED.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO THAT PERSON
WAS FRIENDS WITH.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT CONTACT HE
HAD WITH JOHN BRENNAN.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE KNOW BRENNAN,
WELL, HE HATES DONALD TRUMP AND
HE IS A FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
HE HAS A LOT OF POWER, PROBABLY
AND A LOT OF DEEP STATE FRIENDS
WORKING THERE.
WHAT ABOUT SUSAN RICE?
HER NAME IS MENTIONED IN THE
ARTICLE.
WHAT ABOUT A RELATIONSHIP WITH
ADAM SCHIFF?
WHEN AND WHERE DID HE MEET WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE?
DID SCHIFF OFFICE HIRE A LAWYER
AND WAS AT A SPECIFIC LAWYER?
DID THEY RECOMMEND THE IG?
DID THAT RECOMMENDATION COME
FROM THE COMPROMISING SCHIFF
OFFICE.
WE KNOW THE FIVE LIGHT ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE KNOW HE LIKE THREE YEARS
ABOUT RUSSIA.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID WHEN HE
LIED ABOUT KNOWING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE WOULD LIKE TO, BUT I'M SURE
CONCERNED HE HAS NOT BEEN
ADVISED AS THE LAW REQUIRES BY
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OR THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JUST AS TO HOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS ANOTHER
LIE BY THE COMPROMISED CORRUPT
CONGENITAL LAYER, ADAM SCHIFF.
TONIGHT WE NEED ANSWERS,
REPUBLICANS, IT IS TIME FOR YOU
TO STAND UP FOR DUE PROCESS FOR
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES, FOR THE RULE OF
LAW TO EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS AND YEAH, APPLICATION AS
WELL THAT WILL WORK.
NOW, YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR JOBS.
WE NEED AS A COUNTRY TO GET THE
BOTTOM OF THE IMPEACHMENT.
IT IS A REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WHAT IS BEING REPORTED
BY CLEAR INVESTIGATION ON TOP OF
WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW IT IS
SHOCKING.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT HE IS
RIGHT, IT WOULD REPRESENT
ANOTHER CONFIRMED ATTEMPT AND
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT, AGAIN,
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE REPORTING.
WE HAVE NOT CONFIRMED, AN OBAMA
HOLDOVER WORKING WITH JOE
BRENNAN AND CLOSE TIES TO SCHIFF
AND HIS TEAM.
IN FACT, HE REPORTS THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS A FORMER
COLLEAGUE TO MEMBERS OF SHIFT
DUM XP FIVE CONGRESSIONAL STAFF
AND THAT'S NOT ALL, REPORTING
FOR TIES TO THE DNC OPERATIVE TO
HELP THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
COORDINATE WITH THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE.
THAT IS HOW DEEP THE ALLEGATIONS
GO.
THE MEDIA NEEDS TO GET OFF OF
THEIR BACKSIDE AND BEGAN TO DO
THEIR JOB AND SEE TRUTH.
REMEMBER THE POLITICAL REPORT,
JANUARY 11, 2017 THAT WE
FREQUENTLY REFERENCED, DNC
OPERATIVE COLLUDED WITH UKRAINE,
YES, TO BOLSTER THE CAMPAIGN --
AND THE COURT CONFIRMING UKRAINE
DID, IN FACT COORDINATE WITH THE
DNC AND THEY COLLUDED TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON AND INTERFERE IN
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THAT WAS UKRAINIAN COURT
DECISION.
WE KNOW THE WHISTLE-BLOWER USED
TO WORK WITH UKRAINIAN
INDIVIDUAL WE TALKED ABOUT.
BUT THERE IS MORE, HIS CLAIM SAY
THIS INDIVIDUAL HATED TRUMP, WAS
NOT SHY ABOUT SHARING THOSE
OPINIONS.
IN FACT, THIS REAL CLEAR REPORTS
FROM HE WAS PREVIOUSLY ACCUSED
OF LEAKING INFORMATION TO DAMAGE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DOES HE HAVE AN ENGINE STOMACH
AGENDA?
ALL INDICATIONS POINT TO A
POSSIBILITY, MAY BE LIKELIHOOD
OF ANOTHER DEEP STATE POLITICAL
HIT JOB.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT WE KNOW THAT WILL.
WHAT WE KNOW IS, WHAT WAS THE
CONTACT WITH THE CORRUPT AND
COMPROMISE CONGENITAL LAYER,
ADAM SCHIFF'S OFFICE?
WHAT WAS THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
JOE BIDEN AND ANY OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES.
WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
BRENNAN WHO USED TO BE HIS BOSS?
NO WONDER SCHIFF REFUSED TO CALL
THIS GUY.
WE DON'T NEED TO TALK TO HIM
ANYMORE BECAUSE HE KNEW THE
REPUBLICANS WOULD ASK THE
QUESTIONS.
AND EVEN WORSE THAN WHAT WE DO
KNOW.
IN OTHER WORDS, NOT A REAL
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE KNOW HE HAS ANTI-TRUMP,
DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS.
WE KNOW HE'S A HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER BECAUSE HE HATES
DONALD TRUMP.
HE THINKS HE KNOWS BETTER THAN
WEEK, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO IT IS TIME FOR THE CORRUPT
COMPROMISE, COWARDLY,
ADAM SCHIFF, CONGENITAL LIAR AND
ALLIES TO COME CLEAN.
THE PUBLIC MUST NOW DEMAND THAT.
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF THE
MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
IT IS CLEAR TONIGHT IN AMERICA
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THE MEDIUM UP IN THE DEEP STATE,
THEY HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
WORK HAND-IN-HAND.
THEY WANT TO FUNDAMENTALLY
DESTROY THE VERY FOUNDATION OF
THIS GREAT DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
THAT IS NOW INDISPUTABLE AT THIS
POINT.
AFTER TOP-SECRET TRIAL, NO DUE
PROCESS, FLAGRANT WITNESS
TAMPERING, PREDETERMINED OUTCOME
SPURRED BY AN APPARENT
DEEP STATE OPERATIVE
MASQUERADING AS A
WHISTLE-BLOWER, SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY NANCY PELOSI ASKING FELLOW
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO RUSH
THROUGH AND AUTHENTICATE SECRET
SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT COUP
ATTEMPT.
HOUSE MEMBERS WILL NOW HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THE
CORRUPT COMPROMISE, CONGENITAL
LIAR ADAM SCHIFF WILL GET A
GREEN LIGHT TO TAKE THE TOP
SECRET WITCH HUNT PUBLIC.
MOST LAWMAKERS HAVE NOT BEEN
ALLOWED TO ATTEND THE CLOSED
DOOR HEARINGS, EVEN FEW
EVIDENCE, REVIEW TRANSCRIPTS,
YET THEY WILL NOW AS TO BE ABLE
TO AUTHENTIC HATE A CLOSED-DOOR
PROCESS THEY KNOW VERY LITTLE
ABOUT.
ESSENTIALLY, IT IS A VOTE, AND
THIS VOTE TOMORROW, THIS VOTE
WILL BE A VOTE FOR A PROCESS
THAT IS RUN BY ADAM SCHIFF.
THAT GUY IS THE SINGLE MOST
CORRUPT, THE BIGGEST LIAR IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND THAT SEWER
SWAMP WHICH SAYS A LOT.
THAT GUY HAS BEEN TWO PLUS
YEARS, RIGHT THERE BLATANTLY
LYING AND PUBLIC COME ON TV,
SAYING HE HAS ALL THE EVIDENCE
OF TRUMP, RUSSIA COLLUSION.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER SOME OF THESE
LIES.
WE HAVE HAD FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS, FBI, MY HOUSE
UNTIL INVESTIGATION BIPARTISAN/
BIPARTISAN/SENATE INVESTIGATION
AND THE MUELLER REPORT, THAT
CONTRADICT WHAT HE WAS
TELLING US.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE WAS ALREADY AMPLE
EVIDENCE IN THE PUBLIC ON THE
MAIN ISSUE HAVE COLLUSION.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO SEE IT.
IF YOU WANT TO BLAME YOURSELF,
THEN YOU CAN LOOK THE OTHER WAY.
CERTAINLY SAY WITH CONFIDENCE,
THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE BETWEEN THE
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
>> I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR OVER THE
LAST YEAR, YEAR AND A HALF THERE
IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
IN PLAIN SIGHT.
>> Sean: NO EVIDENCE IN CLEAR
SIGHT AND CONGENITAL LIAR, HIS
LIES DID NOT STOP THERE, THIS IS
A GUY THAT COMPLETELY FABRICATED
THE TRANSCRIPT AND HAD TO MAKE
IT UP.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE IN
AN OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE HEARING.
THAT IS THE GUY WHO LIED ONCE
AGAIN ON TV ABOUT NOT HAVING
CONTACT WITH A HEARSAY, NONE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER.
AND BY THE WAY, HE IS THE GUY
THAT'S BEEN TAMPERING WITH
VIRTUALLY EVERY WITNESS BROUGHT
BEFORE HIS SECRET SOVIET STYLE
IMPEACHMENT WHO ATTEMPT INQUIRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY.
THEY HAVE BEEN FAT AS MOST OF
THESE DEPOSITIONS, BUT TO
INTERRUPT US CONTINUALLY TO
COACH THE WITNESS TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO ASK THE WITNESS.
WE DON'T GET WITNESSES AT THIS
POINT.
AND IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE WILL
GET ANY EVER.
BUT DO NOT LET US ASK QUESTIONS,
I HAVE NEVER, EVER HAD THAT.
TO SEE SOMEONE COACH A WITNESS.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME.
SCHIFF IS VERY GOOD AT COACHING
WITNESSES, REMEMBER?
HE ALSO MET WITH A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
SO THIS IS JUST UNPRECEDENTED.
>> Sean: NOW, WHETHER A
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, YOUR
GOAL, IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO BE TO FIND THE TRUTH AND HAVE
DUE PROCESS.
YOU DON'T SHUT DOWN A WITNESS.
YOU DON'T COACH A WITNESS.
YOU DON'T STOP A WITNESS FROM
ANSWERING A QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
DON'T LIKE THE QUESTION.
IN FACT, IF YOU HAVE ANY
FIDELITY AT ALL TO OBJECT TO
TRUTH, COMMON SENSE, REASON,
JUST AS SOME OF THE CONSTITUTION
OF PROCESS, YOU MUST IMPLEMENT
DUE PROCESS IN ANY TRIAL OR
INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS WHY PAST IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS, IN SHORT, FOR
EXAMPLE NEWT GINGRICH WITH
BILL CLINTON.
THE DEMOCRATS GUARANTEED
RICHARD NIXON.
THEY WERE NOT STRIPPED OF
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
THAT IS NOW HAPPENING HERE.
BUT THE LATEST RESOLUTION DOES
THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
THAT IS THE ONE THAT WILL BE
VOTED ON BY THE DEMOCRATS
TOMORROW.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO WATCH.
IT WOULD GRANT, YES, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR, COMPROMISE
CORRUPT ADAM SCHIFF AND FELLOW
DEMOCRATS THE POWER TO VETO ANY
WITNESS, ANY EVIDENCE, ANY
PROCEDURE.
BASICALLY, THEY CAN DO ANYTHING
THEY WANT.
THERE IS NO DUE PROCESS.
IS THERE ANY FAIR-MINDED
DEMOCRAT, CONGRESS PEOPLE OUT
THERE TONIGHT?
WHEN YOU PUT YOUR HAND ON THE
BIBLE AND YOU SWEAR TO UPHOLD,
PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, IS
THIS WHAT YOU HAD IN MIND?
IS THIS WHAT DUE PROCESS LOOKS
LIKE TO YOU?
IS THIS REALLY THE BEST WAY TO
GET TO THE TRUTH?
AT THE END OF THE DAY COME IF
YOU DECIDE TO SACRIFICE AMERICAN
IDEALS, PRINCIPLES,
CONSTITUTIONAL ORDER, YOU WILL
BE CREATING A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
AND WHAT ARE YOU GAINING?
ACTUALLY, WE HAVE ONE ON US
DEMOCRAT FROM NEW JERSEY WHO
PLANS TO VOTE AGAINST THE
WITCH HUNT TOMORROW.
PERFECTLY TO "CBS NEWS" FROM
NEW JERSEY AND OBVIOUSLY, HE
SAYS HE WON'T BE IMPEACHED AND
IT WILL GO TO THE SENATE.
I BELIEVE IN THE SENATE, HE WILL
BE MEETING THE PRESIDENT BEING
VINDICATED AND THAT IS
CONGRESSMAN ANDREW FROM
NEW JERSEY.
"I THINK WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY
AND TIME AND HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO GET A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS
DONE" ANDREW IS 1 OF 5 DEMOCRATS
SO FAR WHO ARE NOT SUPPORTING
THIS CORRUPT IMPEACHMENT
LACKING DUE PROCESS RESOLUTION
AND I WANT TO INCLUDE ANTHONY
VAN TC FROM NEW YORK MIGHT
DARREN GOLDMAN, COLLIN PETERSON
FROM MINNESOTA.
WHAT DO THEY ALL HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY REPRESENT DISTRICTS ONE BY
DONALD TRUMP IN 2016.
THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
31 LAWMAKERS WITH DISTRICTS
CARRIED BY THE PRESIDENT.
THESE LAWMAKERS RIGHT THERE WILL
THEY VOTE TO OVERRIDE THE WILL
OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS BASED ON A
ONE-SIDED SECRET TRIAL RUN BY,
WELL, IT COMPRISED, LAYER BY
ADAM SCHIFF?
SADLY ONE OF THE PEOPLE ON THESE
LISTS COME AT THE NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN MAX ROSE IS DREADING
RIGHT NOW TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND HE BELIEVES THE PRESIDENT IS
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT.
TELLING THE NEW MAGAZINE "THE
PRESIDENT SAYS HE IS INNOCENT.
SO ALL WE ARE SAYING IS PROVE
IT."
OH, I DIDN'T KNOW IT WORKED THAT
WAY.
IS THAT WHAT YOU REALLY BELIEVE
CONGRESSMAN ROSE?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT.
THIS IS WHY REPUBLICANS KEVIN